a college football analyst for the CBS
and the CBS Sports Network you can catch
him throughout the season on college
football today on CBS and inside college
football on CBS Sports Network which has
a packed lineup of games this weekend
including multiple ranked teams
highlighted by a number 19 Stanford
taking on San Diego State he's good
friend Rick Neuheisel how are you Rick
rich I'm well how are you my friend I am
doing just fine
Anthony munos just left the studio in
the Eclipse a freshman at UCLA I walked
down here this is back when UCLA was
played in the Coliseum right and he and
Keith van Horn and Brad buddy and Roy
Foster that was their offensive line I
looked at him I'm going we are going to
die he's still that big they still
enormous were enormous and what a great
player what a great night where now he
said he had an interesting take on on
the fact that did you see that USC is
says that there's there's they're
undefeated against Texas going this
week's game what do you think about that
that they say do you know all time they
have they have an explanation but to put
that in the notes when you're playing
Texas I don't know that it was necessary
I certainly understand the reasoning but
it isn't as though we've forgotten that
epic game in 2005 been in Vince Young
performance it was one for the ages well
they said that the that the NC double-a
said that they had to vacate all the
games wins and losses from that season
based on what happened with Reggie Bush
and so they apparently have like a
letter from the NCAA Department of stats
or whatever it's called to say that
they're in the right to say that they
didn't lose that game again again they
may have a absolute defensible position
but it isn't like we forgot that
performance on that stage that was a
star-studded evening and Mack Brown's
crew came out on top and Vince young as
I said one for the ages that's right
Rick Neuheisel joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show ok so you've got Clemson
against Louisville this week how do you
think that's going to play out between
the defending
champs as by the way it looks like
Deshawn Watson's gonna get his first NFL
start here tonight in Cincinnati taking
on Lamar Jackson what do you think what
I think you know we all remember gameday
traveling to Louisville a year ago about
this time when Florida State came into
town right and they put a show on that I
don't think anybody's going to forget
they that sixty three points they hung
on Charles Kelly's defense and Jimbo
Fisher that's going to be one of those
things that they'll show over and over
again when Louisville gets ready to go
back to and play the rematch in
Tallahassee but this defense that
they're playing in this particular game
Jared Stidham at Auburn got all he
needed of it 11 sacks last week in Death
Valley in a game that offensively they
struggled but give a burns defense a lot
of credit
you know they win the game 14 to 6
they're coming in there and if you look
at the stat line last year as great as
Lamar Jackson was and he was stupendous
forty seven sacks rich forty seven sacks
last year against one of the best
athletes to ever play quarterback and
and to me that is a recipe for disaster
especially coming in with it with a
group of guys that is hungry for more
after 11 sacks against it him and
company so I'm leaning towards Clemson
it wouldn't shock me of Louisville gets
it done and if in fact it does happen if
it comes to pass we're all going to be
talking about Lamar and you know the
duplicating his Heisman effort from a
year ago but really the story should be
about Bobby Petrino because it wasn't so
long ago that Bobby Petrino was left for
dead that motorcycle accident in
Arkansas I mean who could have imagined
that he'd be back on this kind of stage
taking a program that you know was lucky
to get into the ACC when Maryland
departed for the big ten and here they
are
you know capturing the nations of
attention on a stage against the
defending national champs with a
quarterback that wears a cape I mean
it's a phenomenal story so when if if
Clemson wins this thing you take a look
at the rest of their schedule you could
pretty much pencil them in right to the
well they have another game at the end
of a month you know if Clemson gets
through September I think they're in
really good shape and that all depending
on how James Blackmon the replacement
quarterback
there at Florida State does but assuming
that he struggles like a lot of freshmen
do then I would say yes but that
Virginia Tech game on September 30th
looms large that that kid there Josh
Jackson the true freshman he came out of
the box hot against West Virginia 200
yards passing a hundred yards on the
ground and Justin Fuente he's got kind
of a reputation now as a quarterback
whisperer so I wouldn't I wouldn't rule
that one out especially when the games
in Blacksburg Rick Neuheisel joining me
here in the Rich Eisen show does Urban
Meyer have a quarterback problem Rick I
don't think so I you know I read all
these accounts of the you know
confidence issues with JT Barrett all I
do is go back to his freshman year where
he had 34 touchdown passes in almost a
thousand yards rushing to me the issue
oh hi Oh state is more about kind of a
musical chairs of offensive coordinators
and offensive philosophy right it was
Tom Herman just a few years ago when
they won a national championship then
they had that you know you know musical
chair deal with quarterbacks were
Cardale Jones had one so they got him
some reps and JT did his job but when
they put JT Barrett back in the game and
ran him at the season's end against both
Michigan and Notre Dame he had over 300
yards rushing in those two games
combined and over 300 yards passing as
well that's JT Barrett's best offense
and that's what I know Kevin Wilson and
Ryan day the co-coordinators there now
are trying to get their stamp on it
but if they'll just go back and look at
JT Barrett's legs churning and making
all kinds of plays there's plenty of big
plays that can come off of that and
ultimately that's where they've got to
find the happy balance and I wouldn't be
surprised if Urban Meyer doesn't get
back into that offensive play calling
mm-hmm
and so as we're sitting here in middle
September just assuming Alabama's gonna
be in the big game again which is
assumption
okay so then which team do you think out
there has the best chance to to beat
them this year let's say this about
Oklahoma
you know Baker Mayfield stole the show
with planting the flag and going 16 for
17 in the second half but that defense
was much improved rich that defense gave
up 854 yards to Texas Tech last year 854
yards that defense the other night
looked like it could do damage and what
I think is kind of telling this year in
college football is kind of this really
fats Auburn and Clemson played a whale
of a defensive game the other night
Georgia and Notre Dame played a whale of
a defensive game the other night and
truthfully Oklahoma did as well so to me
with Baker Mayfield and his ability to
run the Lincoln Riley offense and the
the run-pass option thing which is like
dealing from the bottom of the deck in
Vegas it's almost cheating when you can
do that as well as they can there's
clearly in the hunt but they got to get
by Oklahoma State I think Mason Rudolph
and all that those talented receivers in
the big 12 at Oklahoma State are really
really gonna give them a challenge now
that bedlam moved a little earlier in
the season then moved it earlier in the
season because it's a big 12
championship game in which they could
play twice right right and then don't
forget USC for you know out bullying
Stanford you know Stanford had taken
over the pac-12 is the Bullock's they
were the guys who had the line of
scrimmage Washington gave them a little
bit of their own medicine a year ago and
got to the Final Four USC that was a
very impressive performance the other
night in the Coliseum putting over 300
yards of rushing on Stanford that's
that's unheard of so I think the pac-12
champions going to be in the in the
conversation as well so if I had to give
you Rick Neuheisel one quarterback to
win an NFL game in Los Angeles this
weekend and you're not allowed to choose
Philip Rivers he's out of the mix and
you got to choose Sam Donald Josh Rosen
or Jared Goff who would you choose -
well I love golf and and so I'm gonna
lean on the guy with a little bit of NFL
experience but both darn 'old and Rosen
I promise you NFL scouts are salivating
because they are exactly I said this
before the season started Donald's like
Roethlisberger you know he can play from
the pocket he's really good from the
pocket but when he gets out of the
pocket he's lethal and and he's
continued to do that and Rosen's first
two games nine touchdown passes his
ability to put balls where he wants to
put them with the amount of trajectory
necessary they get there in a hurry and
he's looked tough doing it takes tannin
in the pocket and taking it on the chin
I mean he looked exactly like we saw the
Minnesota Viking quarterback
the other night look rad force dance
yeah Bradford and Bradford was uncanny
in that showdown with drew brees if if
rosin continues to play and he can keep
his off-field annex to a minimum I think
those guys have begun what what do you
mean by off field antics well he
sometimes you know has this you want to
you know take it take a big podium and
and want to talk too much and and
there's some NFL guys that are concerned
about that you know you know that the
hot tub in the in the in the dorm room
the stances on college football athletes
you know are they should they be asked
to go to school as well as play and they
don't go together
those those positions may be may be
defensible but why why do what are you
doing why don't you stay in your lane
and play the game as you can play it as
well as anybody and if he can do that
and I think he'll people close to him
will talk to him about doing that and I
know Jim Moore is trying to get that
also done I think he's gonna I think
he's a he's a fabulous player and I've
been up close and personal you know my
son was on that team for a little bit
I've watched him he can flat spin it so
you think that when I'm at the combine
with the network next February and maybe
all of these kids are gonna be there the
conversation around Josh Rosen is gonna
be in the interview room talking to him
to see if if he's gonna create be the
smartest guy in the room that that's
gonna be the question does Josh Rosen
have to be the smartest guy in the room
is he one of those guys that when lend
can tend to be uncoachable or is he
gonna take the information and and
really glean from it there therein lies
a big deal and it's because he's got a
strong personality which is kind of kind
of backward because we all want strong
personalities we want that leadership
guy we want that guy who's intelligent
who's not only quick to its body but
quick twitch mine and certainly Rosen's
in that category but how important is it
to you and how teachable are you and and
I think it's also beneficial for ROS in
terms of his NFL stock that Jed fish is
now there because Jed fish has been in
the NFL he know he's probably teaching
him an NFL offense certainly in that
second half against A&M it looked
fellas and his ability to go right down
the field and lead that team
insurmountable odds was was something to
marvel at miss talking to you Rick I
really do would love to have you on in
studio and my wife Susie knew that you
were coming on to you want me to say hi
to you hey we were great together as
there's no time ever did steal your show
from yeah let's do it together Rick you
got it that's a that's a you got that's
Rick Neuheisel again he is with CBS
Sports and CBS Sports Network Stanford
taking on San Diego State part of the
package that's on the CBS Sports Network
this college football weekend the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked some of that get
some more of that on the Rich Eisen show
app follow all the information you see
right here on the Rich Eisen show